so
my last film touched upon
were all different
and it also touched upon
me starting Ikea
I talked about
being a young man working as a motor
mechanic I worked for myself
and it was very important that I got as
many customers I could because at 23
when I started Aikido
I just had a new baby girl
I'd taken on a mortgage of a new house
and my commitments
of traveling costs
paying the rent on my small shed
trying to buy tools as as I needed them
to build my small business
so the the van that broke down
later on in the day the painter came and
he said to me
um would you like my business I have
three vans and a car
and I said oh yes please I you know I'd
like your business well he was so
pleased that I'd helped his uh
painter and decorate her out that he
wanted I thought at the time
to be kind to repay me
but it came with a snack
a catch I should say
um I didn't realize but he said oh I do
Aikido I'm
a teacher's assistant
and we're about to start a new
beginner's course
and um
if you are prepared to come to this
beginner's course and do the whole
course
I'll give you at the end of it I'll give
you my business for 12 months
and then we can see where it goes from
there
I had no idea what Aikido was I was far
too busy working I would work from six
in the morning till 10 at night
on Sundays I forced myself to work from
10 in the morning till three in the
afternoon
so I was putting in all these hours
I was earning a living I was keeping
busy
and in the book it tells you other
points
but I went to the beginners
class and it was a one one at school and
any of you that know about schools they
work in term time so this was they had
to get I think it was 12 people I think
they had to have so many before the
course could be run
and perhaps that's why he was trying to
recruit people
so I turned up in jeans and a short
sleeve t-shirt
Jane's room my normal blue denims
I had a red t-shirt this is how far I
can remember back and what I was wearing
on the very first night
they had to have
enough people and they they got enough
just enough
I met the teacher
I didn't know at the time but he had had
around three heart attacks
mild ones but they were severe enough
that he had to be hospitalized each time
but he was still prepared to do Aikido
he was a first Dan and he'd moved from
London where he'd gained his first down
and this was at the Hillingdon Hut
it was a it was a wooden old wooden
building
from the Second World War
that had been used and it was behind a
pub
and a small car park in Hillingdon
so
he come from good quality
background because that Hillingdon was
the first place ever for Aikido to be
taught and it was taught there by
kenshiro Abby the great famous Judo
master
he'd been to CEO sansi and he was coming
to teach Judo but he at the time was so
impressed with our senses Aikido that he
showed the Judo people a few Aikido
techniques
and said if you like these techniques I
will send a master called nakazono to
teach you
because he will be teaching only Aikido
they agreed
and
a plus Aikido blossomed in the UK from
this point
in this place onwards
so I wasn't really interested in the
lineage I was only interested in getting
this 12 months business from this Patron
decorator
three vans and a car meant that I could
more likely cover all my rent for the
year in this small shed
well at the time was I believe 11 pounds
a week
it was very small amount
it wasn't not so small then back in
1973.
anyhow
as the weeks went by the time time I
think from what I remember in three
months
and let's say 12 weeks it's not so
important these facts
each week
as the weeks went by
they
were getting Less in numbers
we got down to seven and the teacher
said
I think the class is going to have to
close
because if we drop below a certain
number the school says it's not worth
continuing
but
everybody had paid so the number in the
first place was enough
the men was paid the the full fees
even if they didn't turn up so the
school had their money
we were allocated a room
and so therefore
it wasn't so much that it was going to
end
But the teacher had to make new
arrangements and these Arrangements were
going to be made to move 12 miles from
where I lived in this Village
to Cambridge the main city
we moved to the main city where it was a
judo club that had permanent mats down
they were a very big
Judo club and they could afford to leave
the maps down all the time they rented
the hall had been going on for many many
years so there was no fear of it folding
so we moved to this where I became a
yellow belt
I earned my grade and this was once a
week it was once a week in the school it
was once a week in the
Judo Club
by the time I got my yellow belt I I was
so enjoying it
that every day I was thinking how much I
enjoyed this Aikido and I don't know why
it grabbed me in such a way because I'd
been doing many hobbies before that but
the Hobbies were keeping
um canaries
keeping
up tropical birds
keeping a Dutch a breed of Dutch rabbits
I was a Motocross professional Rider
I was a rallycross driver you know I had
all these different
things I'd done from one scale to
another
I've had nothing to do with sports I was
not a sports person but this Aikido
seemed to just hit the buttons and made
me feel alive in a in a different way in
my body
so I'll continue this story shortly I'm
trying to paint your picture
of what my Aikido and journey has been
so far
I was
only doing Aikido for the greed of
wanting somebody's business
to support my family that's not so much
a bad thing is it
but the main greed was I wanted his
business
to get money so that I could survive in
this small shed and build my business
there
the tragedy was I was quite happy with
the business that I had
plus his business that I gained because
I did do the 12 weeks and went on to
Cambridge Judo Club
but
all of a sudden the garage the Large
Garage next door said
to me one day you're going to have to
get out and find somewhere else Tony
because
we're going to sell up
you see and it's not so easy to just
find somewhere that you can rent cheaply
and also where will all the people come
I didn't have such things as databases
they just knew where to come through
through Word of Mouth one custom I would
tell another customer
most of you would have heard of the
store John Lewis
I gained a manager from John Lewis
he liked me a lot he liked how I would
collect his car take it back he started
introducing the people from John Lewis
to me
one after the other I would get their
customer they would tell their family
it started to grow
what would I do if I moved on
so my accountant because everybody had
to have account and how small you are
tax reasons he suggested that I took on
the main garage
he worked out how I could do it so I
went to the bank borrowed some money
took on the main garage
I'm telling you all this because I'm
trying to build a picture that my life
was not easy
I lived 17 miles away from the garage
so I had to go home to change if I
wanted to go to aikido
and then drive another 12 miles back
into Cambridge
my passion for Aikido was so great that
I was prepared to forsake
once a week
my working hours to go to aikido because
the buzz that I got from my keto
you put that white suit on
and your belt on and you become an alien
you become a person that is not of the
world outside the ones you don't like
and the ones you do like in life you
step onto that match and it's only you
and the pleasure that you're getting
from the art
continue the story shortly
thank you for listening